[Music]
well thank you very much for turning up
at 9 o'clock I'm Damian Laura I'm a
managing director at Google cloud and we
were to talk to you about how to build
top notch marketing technology at scale
and a little bit about myself I almost
11 years in Google I spent two years
running our publisher network in Europe
then six years running our double-click
ad technology in Europe and I've been
two and a half years in cloud and I'd
love to get an idea but who is in the
room how many of you are actually
building marketing technology that you
sell as a SAS solution ok so that's
about half of the room how many of you
build marketing technology within an
enterprise for a marketing department
our to support marketing department ok
um how many of you are our users of
marketing technology yourselves anyone
in the wrong session oh that's the first
time Sony's actually answered that
question good man so and this is a
really really exciting space the number
of our tech and Mar tech companies we
talked to either chief Mar tech or to
luma you know the famous loom escape
that is getting like as more and more
companies get launched the size of
everybody's logo gets smaller and
smaller so but um chief marketing
actually very helpfully provided Google
Doc with all of the the names of the
companies that they actually list in
they're impossible to read poster and
it's over 10,000 marketing and
advertising technology companies that
they've now identified in the space
which is is it's pretty amazing how much
growth we're seeing in this area and
it's it's no surprise because you know
we're still trying to solve those
fundamental opportunities and challenges
that all marketers have like how can we
understand our customers better and
really personalize their experiences how
can we measure better across all the
channels and drive really really
excellent ROI and how can we unlock the
creativity of our teams so instead of
them having day to day
work that doesn't Drive a lot of value
like freedom ought to really be able to
do at top value work and then of course
you've got so many different changes in
the environment you've got like the huge
shifts we saw over the last years in
consumer behavior towards mobile and of
course now everybody wants to see how
they can use machine learning to really
drive efficiency effectiveness and value
so am and this is only getting more
important I think for the enterprise
this is a pretty amazing stat that 22%
of a company's marketing budget is
actually spent on technology and from
all of the analysts I talked to I think
this number will only go up because of
the promise that marketing technology
holds for everybody and they really want
to use there's a really fascinating set
of trends happening about how CMOS and
CTOs and CIOs how that is converging
there's another stat about how like CMOS
are actually controlling more and more
of an enterprises technology budget
because the enterprise sees how this
technology can actually drive top-line
revenue and growth for the company so
that's very very interesting to us here
in Google Cloud obviously not only are
we talking to CEOs and CIOs but we're
now actually looking to talk to the
business line folks and show how Google
cloud can drive real business impact for
them and so here's some of the
opportunities and challenges that we
hear from people like you and that we
need to address when we're thinking
about building marketing technology so
obviously creating tools to allow
marketers your customers to meet their
needs and we hear a lot about people
wanting to leverage machine learning and
how to make sense of it on how to take
action on us and unlocking innovation
throughout your organization I think
that's a really important part to think
of is how do you make things easier and
faster for the people that are actually
using the tools so that they can focus
on what every CEO wants which is
focusing on driving growth and driving
revenue so as competition increases of
both for people who people in the room
who are building marketing technology
tools that you sell us as a solution or
people who are building tools and
within a business you're all focused on
wanting to drive innovation
differentiation for your customers be
the internal or external and the
sophistication of those solutions is
only growing so how can we help so first
of all you know in my journey to cloud
one of the things that attracted me to
Claire after eight years working on the
on the MARTA cannot excite at the
business in Google was I had a
hypothesis that think about Google
Claire it is it's the externalization of
the technology that we use to drive the
largest search and digital marketing
company on the planet so I wondered what
that technology be really good at
solving marketing technology and
marketing analytics problems considering
it was actually built for a marketing
technology company and I think that the
answer is best answered by people like
yourselves but in in working with well
over a hundred companies over the last
two years I think we've been able to see
really really clear examples of where
Google said leap does excel in this
particular space because of the way that
our cloud was built but also because of
our deep domain knowledge within
marketing and I look at we have over
seven and products that have over a
billion monthly active users on our
platform and this has really helped us
to understand the type of innovation
scaling security issues that you're
facing every day and we want to help
that infrastructure that we've built
really support you in your goals and
what you're looking to build so let's
talk about three different areas where
we think we can really help that we
stand out in so developing features and
products faster helping you to scale
globally and efficient pricing let's
start off with feature and product
development first so that's talking
about main ad I'm actually going to talk
through some customer examples here
rather than just talking about like
conceptually how can Google help you so
um this is a real-time main out is a
real-time bidding a programmatic ad
retargeting company and they're
originally running at
50,000 requests per second but they
recognized that they needed to grow
faster um and in moving to Google cloud
the important part was actually the
impact on their business outcome they
were actually able to improve their
bidding accuracy by 75% and obviously
being a performance management company
performance marketing company that made
a huge difference to both are they were
able to provide to their customers and
also their own business outcomes they
launched a new platform on Google cloud
and focused on AI machine learning and
and in doing that they were able to
apply real-time predictive analytics to
ad retargeting and again a very very
significant impact on their conversions
which is big part of their business big
part of their growth and how to make
money for themselves and for their
customers in terms of scaling globally
and I've on a number of occasions
actually shared the stage with Don from
infectious media and I think his story
is is pretty fantastic
he actually um he pretty gleefully talks
about the fact that he originally built
the technology infrastructure on a
different cloud and and then just could
not scale and actually made the decision
that III haven't come across like that I
just asked the audience he actually
moved from cloud back to on pram in
order to be able to deal with some of
the performance issues he was saying and
I'm just asking it has anyone else done
that have you moved from cloud back to
on Prem it's not a direction we see a
lot of people go um and oK we've it he
could he explained the logic of it in
terms if he did actually solve his
performance problem but all that
happened was he then had a gigantic
scaling problem the scaling problem was
that his course started scaling linearly
back when he was on pram so he actually
hit a point where they really wanted to
launch in a pack in Asia and they knew
that was going to be a huge huge growth
in their business that's the record in
this dilemma of whether they were going
to launch on pram and then migrate to
Google cloud or whether they would
actually move to Google cloud and then
launch but they knew that there was a
huge amount of revenue and business that
they
if they either made a mess of it or if
they delayed too long so we were able to
convince them that they could actually
do both in a very very short period of
time and they it went very very well for
them they actually migrated her their
entire business in a week with no
downtime then launched in a pack which
quadrupled their business and one of the
most amazing stats about that is that at
4x the size so they went from 35,000
transactions per second to four times -
after launch in a pack their cost base
remain the same compared to what they'd
been on pram so they were absolutely
delighted with both the performance the
scalability and the cost so actually
that's the next area they want to talk
about efficient pricing so it's moving
to the cloud is not all about saving
money and but we do recognize that
efficient pricing is a very very
important and part of your business
model so and we want to think of it in
terms of by providing efficient pricing
that you only pay for what you use that
gives you more resources that you can
reinvest in your business and reinvest
in growth and so nor X also programmatic
advertising platform also totally
focused on scalability and speed and
they wanted to build out their real-time
bidding functionality powered by machine
learning um here they did they moved
across and they got an immediate 30
percent reduction in cost which they
were then able to reinvest in the growth
of their business they actually um said
that although that was great that
one-time cost reduction was fantastic
what they appreciated even more was
their freeing up their precious
developer resources from doing
operational tasks and getting them to
actually be able to develop the tools
and the technologies that were actually
going to drive growth and revenue for
their business so it's the combination I
think of the freeing of resources that
losing the opportunity cost and then of
course there is a cost benefit obviously
of moving to the cloud and so what does
this mean for your business and so we've
built our cloud to be hyper efficient
very security-conscious scalable for our
selves and we now want to bring that to
you and help you transform the way you
can build your own marketing technology
so this stage I'd like to invite my good
friend Sudhir husband who's the PM
director for data analytics to the stage
to go even deeper on what we can do to
help you to build out top-notch
marketing technology thank you so as
Damian said I'm a director of products
for data analytics at Google I've been
here around nine months prior to this I
was VP of engineering at Zulily I owned
I built all the data platforms there I
won't add tech merchandising tech
product pricing all of that stuff and I
built all of that over three and a half
years at absolutely so I'm happy to
share some of the experiences from my
past as part of this session but before
that let's actually go and talk about
Google Cloud and what are the key areas
that we try to go ahead and help our
customers right one is the whole
marketing tech is all about big data
your massive amounts of data that you
can collect leveraging that data to do
better segmentation to target right
customers reducing your you know total
cost of acquiring customers getting
better return on investment so it's all
around data analytics it's all about
machine learning and I fundamentally
believe that we have the best technology
for for those things in in the world the
other thing is being open and having an
open open source based technology or
being an open cloud is super critical
because all customers do want the
solutions that can run in multiple
environments right most of our customers
are in a hybrid environment especially
with on-premises in cloud on GCP some of
them are across multiple different
clouds so it's important to have
technologies that can actually span
between different different environments
and then of course one of our key
differentiators we don't talk much about
it but one of our key differentiators I
fundamentally believe is our global
network the reach that we have with our
network is pretty amazing in every part
of the world and we'll see a bit of that
but before that let's talk about the
data and
we are a data company fundamentally the
whole Google as a company we collect
massive amounts of data we process that
data we analyze it and we build some
amazing products we damien was saying we
have seven products that are billion
plus active users we are actually going
to be roughly I think eighth one is
coming I heard earlier in the keynotes
with drive enterprise may be reaching
reaching billion user so so that's what
we do we understand users we understand
what they need and we build better
products for them and so so big data is
in our DNA one of the other key
learnings that I have is and this this
is one of the things I think folks or
somebody had the article on this is if
if your company's not good at analytics
you're never going to be good at AI so
fundamentally the first thing I always
say is get better at core analytics get
better at having good data and then then
you'll be able to do machine learning
pretty easily on top of that and one of
the things that we are doing is trying
to get the machine learning tools make
it easier and easier for our audience to
use them and leverage them for solving
problems and I will touch upon couple of
them now this week that we have launched
but from a core platform perspective
what we're trying to do is four things
one we want you to focus on analytics
not on infrastructure so if you look at
some of our products that we are
building they're all server less so you
can literally bring your data in you can
start analyzing it start doing
segmentation start doing targeting just
just based on the data that you have so
you don't need skills to you don't have
to worry about monitoring products you
don't have to worry about managing
scaling infrastructures that's our
problem we will take care of that the
second thing is comprehensive solutions
I will touch upon the whole portfolio of
products we have and how they fit into
what you can do with marketing tech I
will touch upon that more details now we
have an end-to-end machine learning
lifecycle so if you think about it 80%
of the time our data scientists and
analysts spent on is cleaning data and
20% goes into actually doing real
analytics or real machine learning stuff
so we're trying to build tools that are
making it easy for you to go do that now
that whole lifecycle and then of course
innovation we are innovating faster we
are delivering newer and newer products
so this is a whole portfolio of products
I won't go into everything here the key
point I wanted to
and this one is we like if you wanted to
collect real-time events from globally
wherever your customers are and then you
want to take those events as soon as a
person comes on your website on your
mobile device and you want to do a
targeted offer for them or something we
have products across the board so if you
see cloud pub/sub it's a globally
scalable event collection system where
any kind of a clickstream event or
something you can just collect and then
take action on data flow data proc their
large scale of the data processing
solutions where you can get that those
events in real time figure or I will
give a real example and Zulily we did
this where we collected every time poor
people came into the website we
collected those events in clickstream
collected them in a messaging system
real-time aggregated that information
and she just showed it back you see this
on different hotel sites and all n
number of people are watching this room
right now or Y number of people are
buying this stuff now we just did that
it took us like couple of weeks because
we are all pipelines were already in
place immediate uplift in our conversion
rates because that's an instant feedback
for customers what they are doing so
those kind of systems are really easy to
build with now with things like pub/sub
data flow rate up rock and then bigquery
is our large scale data warehouse we'll
talk more about it where it allows you
to go ahead and build large collect
large amounts of data and actually
process it and do segmentation and
things like that and then if you want to
get into advanced analytics you can use
ml engine tensorflow for like real
machine learning at scale here is our
database portfolio again I'm not going
to do a lot of talk on the on specific
products but the most important thing I
would say is as I said bigquery
large-scale data analytics you can do in
that the other side of thing is if
you're looking for a globally scalable
relational database which can be
consistent across the globe for for your
transactions spanner is a solution like
spanner can scale globally we lot of our
internal systems actually leverage
spanner for the consistency across the
globe so that's one of the products that
you should absolutely look at but let's
talk about bigquery for a second because
that's where we have key innovations so
lot of internal analytics that we run in
Google all runs or
on something called dremel that's a
dremel paper externally bigquery is an
externalization of the same technology
so first of all you will use the same
petabyte scale cloud data cloud scale
data warehouse that we internally use
for all our analytics you will use in
your enterprise so that's one key thing
the second key thing here is it's highly
secure it allows you to do real-time
streaming directly into the data
warehouse so you can collect events and
at the same time ingest it directly into
the warehouse and do real-time analysis
somebody checks into the hotel and you
want a analyst to know that instantly
within under a second you can collect
that put it into bigquery you know what
it is and take actions on it so those
are the kind of scenarios you can enable
with this now fully managed and support
standard sequel so most of your analysts
would know some form of sequel and if
they are if they can use sequel for
general analytics bigquery is really
available available for that one of the
things with bigquery we have done is
we're making it really easy for you to
get your advertising information data
from different ad channels and all
especially with Google easily into the
into the into bigquery for example most
of our customers already use Google tech
like Adwords
double-click YouTube play store all of
these different things for advertising
all that data with few clicks you can
literally bullet into bigquery
and so that's one thing and then if you
have some of the data like we have lot
of companies that use drive with sheets
and all to create like some campaign
information and stuff like that which is
like a master information so if it is
there and drive we can just connect to
it without even pulling it into bigquery
so we do both Federation which is like
connecting to external sources but also
moving data into bigquery easily so that
you can you can analyze this at scale
for you other than that we literally
believe in democratizing insights what
what we do is if you built like if one
of the analysts has built segmentation a
query to go ahead and segment your
customers into high value low value
medium value based on let's say their
lifetime spend you can go ahead and
share that with every other analyst
within the organization using now using
the query sharing capability
you can build a data studio how many of
you have tried or used data studio yeah
if you haven't you should absolutely try
it out it's a it's absolutely free the
second thing is it has the latest thing
that we announce the data studio is
pre-built gallery of reports for example
if you're using AdWords for advertising
there's pre build like report in the
report gallery that shows you all your
ad spend analysis and stuff like that
but one of the things you can do is just
take that and connect with bigquery to
start analyzing more in depth what it is
visualize it and share it with your with
your customers or within your
organization with folks one of the
things people do a lot with data studio
is they build those reports and actually
share across organizations so you can
take a report share it with other people
they can use their log in to see what is
relevant to them and stuff like that so
really powerful tool sheets integration
and and one of the most important things
is we have huge partner ecosystem that
also allows you to get data into
bigquery and analyze it and stuff like
that so as I said earlier today in my
introduction I was absolutely I was VP
of engineering there for three and a
half years and built most of the data
systems before that let me talk about
Zulily Zulily is an online retailer a
fashion retailer we launched 9,000
products every day they lasted on the
site only for 72 hours so there's a
sense of urgency to come and buy stuff
because the deals go away it's a daily
deal site more than 5 million active
users when I left it's a public number
and then what does that we used to have
millions of people coming every day
visiting the site trying to look for
different offers and stuff like that
there are few things which was really
critical right when you have that many
people coming in that many products
launching it's not a search based site
it's basically a personalized discovery
kind of an experience that you give
people you have to show person what is
relevant at the right time at the right
moment and the right price because if
you don't do that there's no way of
searching through the catalog which is
so volatile it's not a fixed catalog
system so one of the things that we did
which was collect all the data from our
catalog from all the different vendors
and actually go ahead and personalize
the whole website based on what
people were doing in past and leverage
machine learning for doing lot of that
stuff the second thing was we had 500
merchants or so like really large
merchant population that was responsible
for building they're bringing the right
products in we had to be able to give
them right insights in real time which
customers are buying what kind of
products and how do you optimize that in
real time what should be the right
prices and stuff like that so that was
there how do you make better marketing
decisions like the key thing was how do
you keep the growth on within six seven
years we were like multi-billion dollar
like we company and and that growth rate
was really high how do you get more
customers and how do you do better
segmentation especially reducing your
cost of acquisition was a key priority
for us so here is what we did at a very
high level it's a 10,000 foot level
thing the first thing we did was we
realized when we started on the journey
we need a single source of truth for our
customer so what we did was first we
went to bigquery we tried a lot of
different technology options on promises
option
we tried open source stuff like hive
Hadoop clusters and stuff like that what
we realized was all of them were not
fast enough
we need an interactive level analytical
capability for our analysts right they
are not going to sit there for 25
minutes 30 minutes fire a Hadoop query
and then come back and then get a coffee
come back and it doesn't work like me
they were very clear like our marketing
analytics team was like no no we need
interactivity that is there otherwise
it's not going to work so we leveraged
bigquery for all of that and bigquery we
created some key data sets there's one
data set which was all about customer so
we had all the customers or members that
we had members our customers who haven't
bought anything yet
everybody had a row we had all the
information for them within a single row
and it was like how many times have they
bought what have they bought what's
total money all that was in a single row
that we could get all their activity was
in a related table so that means you had
user here's all the activity on the
product and always dimensional so it was
already there and then we created so
that was one key thing like everything
about your customer we'd there's a lot
of talk about CDP's now customer data
platforms and stuff like that it's
fundamentally just a central place
with all your customer activity
information once you have that now you
can do segmentation you can say hey tell
me all the customers that have come in
last seven days multiple times tell me
all the customers that came seven
multiple times last week and haven't
come back again so we were able to
create these dynamics segments in
bigquery at scale and we means like the
analyst team in marketing analyst team
could start creating those and start
segmenting them because previously what
we we had was hey we have lot of
customers and we send them emails and
that is it like everybody gets an email
and and stuff like that but this allowed
us to do micro segmentation at the scale
we could never do and so that way then
those analysts were able to make those
decisions segment them figure out
anybody who hadn't come last week should
we send them an email and remind them or
maybe give them an offer or if somebody
has been coming consistently not buying
it should we show different products so
those kind of decisions were easier to
make at scale we had like when I left it
was more than a petabyte scale data
total data set that we had but we
started collecting a lot of information
now the second thing as I said we
basically collected real-time events
from the site way as soon as people
landed on the website all the activity
they did what products they were
clicking on what products they were
buying what products were going in the
cart we collected all of that
information the statistics which is
interesting it's actually in the case
study when we started the project like
for real-time collection we are
collecting 50 million events in a in a
day by the time I left we were already
at five billion events a day so it was
an 100x increase in number of events the
thing is once you start seeing value
from data you want more and more
collection and the data volume just
grows so we went from 50 million to five
billion a day we're peaking at like
almost fifty thousand or thirty five to
fifty thousand events a second but the
key thing there was getting that
information in real time ability to
aggregate that information push it back
into the serving platform like website
to go ahead and see how many people are
watching some products are making
decisions like that became really easy
and and we didn't have to worry about
anything because the scaling of the
infrastructure was all taken care of by
by the cloud infrastructure that we had
so we basically I put
all that data leverage data frog for the
cleansing of data making sure the data
was ready for analysts and then all the
data was put into bigquery analysts had
tableau so they use tableau for their
visualizations reporting some amazing
reports to see trend lines about how
many people were coming last year same
day this day today what has the change
is it going up down how many people are
ready to churn out because we had a
metric on active customers all of that
cuz the analyst teams could do by
themselves and then of course we also
took the same data the single view of
customer and their activity and all of
that and also powered our operation
systems we had more than 70 api's that
were built on top of our data sets
within bigquery that allowed different
systems to call in and say hey give me
the performance of the supplier so we
can give a better offer better
estimation for our customers how long it
takes to ship them and all that so all
those kind of things were able to do
just because how we pick the
infrastructure leveraging bigquery for a
lot of those those kind of scenarios one
of the things we launched this this week
was bigquery ml it's a machine learning
capability directly inside bigquery what
it is is very simple you have marketing
analysts they know bigger sequel they've
been running sequel queries analyzing
stuff
bigquery ml actually allows you to do
regression models like linear regression
logistical regression directly inside
the data warehouse so if you have pulled
all your data moved it into a data
warehouse which is already there now you
can write two lines of code to create
regression models and do things it's
pretty interesting and for prediction
you just have to say select ml dot
product and you get predictions back so
it's as simple as that now for the
experience from from an analyst
perspective here are a few examples you
must have if you saw how many of you saw
our day two keynotes
migrated you heard from 20th Century Fox
how they were able to go ahead and do a
linear regression to go ahead and
predict which customers were going to
come back for Maze Runner compared to
all the things that they have done in
past in different movies and also that's
one example there were a couple of other
sessions we were talking about but like
simple things like you want to go ahead
and do logistical
regression for classification which of
your customers are high-value which ones
of them are going to churn which ones
are going to be doing the subscription
or not taking the subscription all that
kind of analysis now you can really do
it inside and run a whole machine
learning model within seconds and do it
one of the other things is we also have
our partners like looker and all
building experiences to bring all of
this together now within it so that's
the bigquery ml we just launched this
this week you should try it out see how
you can leverage that for different
marketing scenarios that you have yeah
other than that we have a huge portfolio
for your AI and m/l capabilities right
from auto ml capability for translation
that we launched a natural language as
well as auto ml for vision which was
already there those are just great tools
for non-technical users or developers to
just move data in tagged them and then
start using the API is or batch
predictions to board and figure out what
and what you want to do additionally if
you have data scientists and PhDs within
your organization they can do complex
neural network based modeling you can
absolutely use ml engine tensorflow all
of those things to go ahead and run
those kind of models the other key thing
we also have is we have this thing
called advanced solution lab where we
work with key customers and partners to
work together on solving some
interesting and major problems that you
may be facing in in partnership so
that's there for the next thing I want
to touch upon is open source solutions
focusing on open source is key value
proposition for us we want to make sure
all the stuff that our customers are
investing in is it's possible for them
to leverage them not just on our cloud
but also on the different environments
you have and then containerization
everybody who's been using kubernetes or
has looked at it it's basically one of
the fastest-growing open source projects
started from within Google we were using
containers making it available I'm not
going to go in depth of this but in 15
years of innovation in Big Data we have
been before
cloud was there we used to actually
publish all these papers and share
whatever we were learning now we are
making them available as different
products like bigquery spanner lot of
other products or we also have products
that provide managed open source
solutions like data proc if you have a
Hadoop environment
how many people have Hadoop environments
within their Hadoop SPARC stuff good so
data proc is basically managed Hadoop
and spark in the cloud so if you you
don't have to worry you don't need
administrators you don't need management
capability just write your scripts in
hive or SPARC and just run it and we
just take care of the whole loading of
the whole machines bringing it down
scaling up and down auto scaling those
are all the investments that we're
making from our side and then composer
is airflow which is if you need a
distributed orchestration capability
pull data from point A go ahead and do
segmentation after segmentation move it
to Adwords or our Facebook or gdn and
then go do something else and send an
email that kind of orchestration you can
do in in airflow pretty easily yeah
other than that you saw some of you must
have seen SST or demo yesterday pretty
cool stuff that's what we are doing from
an open source perspective is to your
kubernetes tensorflow again for machine
learning is all all open source from our
side as I said earlier one of the key
differentiators we have is our global
presence and reach basically if you look
at our global network this is the
network that is powering all of our the
billions of users that we go ahead and
like you know provide solutions for is
the same network we are making available
for our customers it's basically you can
locate services closer to your user
imagine YouTube being watched in all the
different countries how close we need to
be to those users that's the same
network that that we leverage for GCP
it's highly available and then of course
now choose your resources and locations
where you are like if you want to go
ahead and regionalize surf because of
data locality and all maybe provide that
now if you look at our infrastructure
and reach we have hundreds of thousands
of miles of cables fiber-optic cables we
actually have submarines that actually
put down all these cables through oceans
and stuff like that so it's pretty cool
now there are we now are in
fifteen regions that under color six
more coming in 2018 but we had 15
regions 55 zones already so imagine the
whole scale that we that we are putting
together now with that I would like to
call upon my next guest to talk more so
yeah we are build scalable attack system
to handle global traffic within two
years or things to Google infrastructure
so what does the scalability mean to
start up like us we started as our two
co-founders thorough three years ago and
for the first CEO actually moved seven
times and now we started this year with
the 20 team members now we are actually
reaching 250 team members and we are
supporting enterprise customers with a
tens more than like 10,000 employees
right so throughout this like our
journey we always use our infrastructure
on top of Google cloud so no matter we
have two team members 50 team members or
supporting 10,000 employees Google
infrastructure was able to handle the
scalability so we're over overview Obama
local we are over at a company and our
vision is atoning your first party data
into the add performance you know secure
you know a safe way to give you full
control of over your data for last three
years are we on board more than like 60
clients our goal for the last two years
is testing our machine learning
algorithm on different countries and
different verticals so we are now
running our campaigns on 40 different
countries you know for the call from
mobile commerce rather sharing food
delivery to all different kind of own
on-demand
apps so whenever we meet new clients we
are very excited about talking to new
clients a lot overcome we a lot of
startups turning their idea into
directory services and then don't worry
about the service care
anymore because all they are all backed
by cloud computing right but when we
meet when we talk to companies where
they actually are stock ad is a lot of
company has pain for the growth and for
the monetization need and the reason why
is we'll cover this in the next slide
but complexity to build mobile marketing
and monetization platform is becoming
more complex so Google as we covered in
the previous slide our goal our goal and
Google's goal is to support you you need
you know in a fast way so your growth
and business goals cannot be slowed down
so our goal is delivering best modern
technology within a quorum so this is
what we did for last two years are we
now handle more than 600 k7q PS this is
a sixty billion daily requests per day
so what was sixty billion requests mean
is let's say you build some messenger
services without 100 million people if
they text like six six hundred times
text per day there's a 60 billion per
day so this system is built basically in
a scale over something like a
large-scale messenger system in a
country so we manage this carnival scale
of services with a nine infrastructure
team members and on our data pipelines
we run 200 different data flow graphs
for on behalf of our customers on
different verticals and we handle more
than hundred terabytes data today with
the forty thousand virtual CPUs so the
complex so while we build this system we
realize the complexity over
mode on attack and marketing text system
so in all the desktop earth right what
does our ad serving system means it's
basically a content delivery system you
can put your image on on your content
delivery services and you can put a
simple account row on your web pages you
can
account impression and if your client is
we can just count clicks but now
actually your marketing department or
your advertiser they want optimize for
the post clip post installation events
which is happening on advertisers domain
or advertisers app so now I don't
lecture you just need to serve that but
also you need to ingest the data from
your advertiser your clients app so now
you need a not only the DSP services but
also data in JSON services in the
meantime you got to analyze a LTV
customer acquisition cost then is a lot
of big data system which is a TMP and
also you need to have a you need to
support internal analytics groups so
which is neither analytics all the
players right so now we are in the third
day of GCP you probably heard about ton
of different data infrastructure from
spinner cloud storage MEMC called
BigTable right so what should you use
right that's what we kind of tried to
figure out the last two years so each
module each icon here is actually
turning into the proper Google cloud
infrastructure for example on our
serving infrastructure we use current
ease and the GCE and for the TMP we
actually realized that BigTable is most
fastest and scalable way to support
large-scale and infrastructure for the
analytics read big quarry and for the
big data pipeline yes we tried several
different solution we realized that data
flow is the best one and at the last are
the products the brain part right
smarten is how to optimize for to add
performance how to deliver the better
revenue and better cost optimization for
your marketing needs is a key motion
only and we decide to use tensorflow we
recover
born this one in the our last slide so
yeah this actually shows that as
complexity or building modern
architecture and we actually will we
actually figure it out although what is
the best solution for this one with
Google and now that you can use this
system to launch your ad plan
marketing platform the Covidien three
months another interesting observation
we realized when you talk to our
customer is consolidation over marketing
world in global menno so previously like
when you run advertising campaign what
does it mean you normally call agencies
right and hey can you put our ads on
next to 101 or this newspaper so let's
say you go to different country they say
you are expanding to Japan you normally
talk to some big agencies like a tenchu
or some traditional agencies but what we
find very interesting is now actually
the top tech companies they are
consolidating there are ad planning team
and ad execution team in one location or
all only very handful like regional
areas so for example one of the largest
streaming video streaming company they
run all advertising campaign from los
carros or one of the largest like a home
sharing company they run all the
campaign from San Francisco and
Singapore foot and to cover APEC and
global the reason why is marketing is
not only are not just about the page
views or publication it's all about the
big data this it becomes very hard to
duplicate your big data team for every
country right that's a why actually are
consolidating their marketing big data
team and the execution team in new of
your countries so now actually given
that your infrastructure serving system
got to support global traffic so the
question is now some of the ad exchanges
right
for example we are also not only part of
the Google cloud we are also Platinum
Google EDX exchanges they have a
multiple ad exchange servers across the
world cover the global traffic some of
the smaller ad exchanges they only have
our services services in u.s. some of
the local exchanges they have a server
in Japan in Singapore right to figure it
out where they are and to connect and to
design you infrastructure for this
country from the global set up is also
time wasting and time cause it is not
rocket science
should not be focused over your business
but but it's easily waste you're like
six months or one you know right now we
don't know on the website you also got
to interior with uh all these mobile
measurement companies I mean in previous
like that abilities comScore nowadays as
flyer tune some of them have obvious
servers all in us some of them have in
Japan some of them have a multiple
location in global location again to
figure it out we don't want wait we
don't want to like waste time on this
kind of all under works so we actually
figured out everything and Google
infrastructure support or just global
scales for example we run our BigTable
instances in four different locations in
in the world and we run our machine on
intense flow engine on us only so we
actually run some of the dictator
pipelines through the data flow you know
for different locations we actually send
intermediate data to save the the
network traffic cost between the data
centers and the run all the machine
learning jobs from the US and then this
will the result of the machine learning
reject to the other location in the last
like the most like exciting and the
important part is a machine learning how
to turn your data into the real
performance right so as a studio covered
in the previous session Google the
benefit is you can cover end to end
what does end it end means right so you
have a great services your service to
local data and you basically to low but
it has a feedback from your users right
now you've got to turn that data into
the actionable items through the machine
learning and then the action of data the
actionable item should be reflected to
your services now your users react to
the new system and then they'll give
another PDA so this kind of feedback
loop so your business success is depends
on how you firstly iterate this system
and we built all this entertain it right
iteration feedback system so on top of a
Google data infrastructure so for the
robot collections
user profile stories we use the pops up
BigTable and then we use data flow to in
extracted data from those data pipeline
and we feed that data into the pencil
flow so when you first begin yes
it's two years ago tense flow was of it
only and then we also small so we
started up from our sidekick like a
traditional machine learning sitting
right and now as everyone knows you got
to switch to the deep learning system
right so the peripheral of a tense flow
and the Google infrastructure is tends
to flow a lot of people think all is
image recognition oh it's deep learning
it's not it's it also support all the
traditional models so we used to run
different models on a different machine
on infrastructure now with the
tensorflow we actually run all the
traditional leader or logistic
regression models and also keep learning
news team learning models and sometimes
we mix those two models hybrid models
right we test all different kind of
models on top of tensorflow and we
compare the result of these different
models on a through the a B test
platform and we realized in different
vertical in different or data channel
sometimes it's even a traditional model
works better so still our serving system
can support all these different kind of
solving model for different clients need
without like any other extra
infrastructure cost and on top of total
variance of these models right most
exciting part in not only the motor for
us on the line physical layer so we
started from the CPU based training we
are using GPU and most exciting stuff is
now if Google is are launching the
specialized processor for the tensor
flow rate tensor flow unit or GPU so we
can test all these different kind of
physical infrastructure without in
changing any of our infrastructure and
yeah result or we achieve up to like
three times better cost savings or
revenue from for user base in many of
our clients so to wrap up
we grew tremendously for the last few
years without worrying any of the server
infrastructure or spending a lot of
money for the DevOps team we hope you
can grow with a Google like that like us
and we are very excited about the new
and trend watching learning
infrastructure so what we like about
Google is Google's vision on the
scalability and also on the global but
on top of that we what we actually
really like about Google is their
philosophy on the openness right it
actually really resonate to our
philosophy on keeping your data on the
full control on you and how to value
your first party data using this kind of
new technology that's actually our what
we our vision is right thank you
[Applause]
you
[Music]